okay four people joining this live
stream hey we got some background noise
um we are talking about the unity link
for Wolfram language um which has been
the project we've been working on for
quite a number of years but it should
now be becoming mature and it's going to
be released in the next version of the
language so um by the way that is the
bad link type here
that's that shouldn't be the same link
type as these here these are these are
all supposed to be different link types
right Roger yeah I'm gonna have to do a
pass with Brian to figure that out and
in fact all of these things shouldn't be
blue because their package symbols right
they should be that they have this teal
color but they're supposed to be but
that's what I'm saying that needs to be
a pass with Brian okay okay so where do
we start
so let me just preface this a little bit
so these with these things it's very
important to you know how to get started
how to do basic things these are
basically workflow style documentation
that gets you past a lot of things you
know it looks encouraging but this might
be useful it's not finished
yeah I see what your need is not
finished the first example there just
show the format and this is links yeah I
still watch on them I clicked it and it
got bigger I would have expected some
kind of click to copy behavior but um
that is confusing if I might say so to
call the disk disk
I mean well whatever you know you say
call it poly and make it be a polyhedron
oh it isn't a poly regular polygon a
five or some such other thing I would
suggest minor point am I making sense so
so that's that's one side of these
things micro workflows to get you going
yeah so let me try doing this can I try
doing this you have to follow the whole
thing you can't just jump in the middle
I mean he's depend of what you want to
do right I want but I want to put a
dodecahedron in the middle of the unity
scene then if you open a notebook on
load unity
I mean load unity package under unity
open a project you should probably close
your current existing unity because we
cannot open to session
okay so I say here um what do I say here
I load the unity package you need to
link okay
that's by the way an incorrect I mean
you're aware of that that's a that's a
you know a progress dialogue that isn't
of the new type I've given standardized
a new type we're supposed to have that
unification okay it's your pen just ours
let's put a stream my project or
something like that
crabby Skippy Hadi old veterans
okay all right well this is this seems
to be a pretty old version okay well so
I probably shouldn't have skipped the
update you should I do the update yes
so we take some time but yes
what should I do here it's Roger on this
call by chance Roger Dooley is almost
yeah I'm here um any thoughts about this
can we do this in the background somehow
or is it about what do we have to do
here so but this is silly part you
should probably get the 2018 I mean this
is I think couple of years old okay I
mean
okay I don't know what I'm doing here
well let's see if it works
I mean is it going to work or is it
going to fail do you think um it's
actually already fell because normally
when it does the units you open
automatically load the the wall Hamas
said I said we need to actually connect
back to the Chronicle I just did the
download max so what do i what do I want
to do here I just did I already did that
this is the market patch for do your
version which is a body you're old he
sees a ghost mm how do I get the new
version um I think if you go to the
product on top of the page there there
is a link to product and get unity I
mean just take the personal version I
mean you have the professional licensing
will be automatically updating you so
what do I do here if you press on try
personal but it's gonna ask me a bunch
of questions isn't it no there is a
download one day so I can download the
personal version even though I've got a
professional license yes I think he's
doing the I mean when he starts where he
actually I've got the download assistant
now what do I do
I you press on it you probably have to
close your quaint existing one current
existing unity yes um does he have
what what is that what's going on they
start to go to the preference holder and
then to activate the downloader
so I have to login as root or something
okay
why doesn't Roger try and figure this
out meanwhile I will simply look at
documentation for a little bit okay um
okay so the workflow is supposed to be I
say unity open and then what do I do
let's go back to the main page here
depends on who you are okay so and let
me just yeah go ahead go ahead Roger
okay so getting started is a few basic
workflows that you just kind of have to
know and it sort of you know deals with
two environments there's the notebook
Wolfram language notebook environment
and there's the unity environment and it
shows often shows what happens in one
when you do things in in in the other
sample projects are a little bit bigger
where you build like a mini game and
then there's sort of two sides to what's
actually provided one thing is sort of
API bindings for the Wolfram language
and the other side is c-sharp bindings
for Wolfram language kinds of functions
the Wolfram language things are things
you would use obviously in the Wolfram
language and you can sort of remote
control the language remote control the
unity engine you can create objects you
can edit objects you can track objects
you can generate statistics you can you
can convert assets into automatically
into assets into unity of various kinds
you know like geometry images audio
those kinds of things graphics that's
cool on the other side the c-sharp
bindings gives you access to call in the
other way around from the engine into
Wolfram language yep to provide
functionality there's a
a set of things that you can actually
build standalone games apps and those
are unity deployment Sita in the first
section there sort of Wolfram language
functions they allow you to build
complete you know standalone things
okay um now you will have a game on your
desktop let's say wherever it gets put
okay so but this is okay so let me just
try to understand these things so
there's about 500 objects this is about
500 functions yes substantial number
I've seen this cuz I've seen in the kind
of knitting work let's see so let me ask
a few questions so in terms of the
callback from unity to orphan language
what does that um well I'm being told
that I'm I sound very faint here umm
really well I've been using the exact
same configuration forever and ever and
ever so I don't know sound good to me
Roger do you want to comment on that is
there anything I can do here - it's
actually much better now so thank you
very much maybe I just maybe I just
moved the microphone away okay um okay
so let's see I was saying from within
unity there's a callback presumably to
our language which goes through
something like an API function is that
correct
I'm correct so from unity if you see the
second part which we haven't yet fully
documented to have a Wolfram language
class and then you can't do for example
it may toad call evaluate okay so do you
know for example like the the Python
language client library that just got
finished have you guys seen that briefly
but never use it
okay because that's a that's a
comparable situation right where it's
calling in too often language from
Python right yes and I mean I'm not an
expert so with respect to the you know
dotnet link this must be similar is it
similar to dotnet link or is it not
similar to that um it's pretty similar
because they pretty much should the same
interface yes so it's almost the same I
mean it's dot it's mono so it's not like
this dot evaluate thing is that
something where you give it a string
like you can say 2+2 or something
exactly and you get back his tween
you got like a string yes is that good
and I mean are there not native types
that you can get back yeah we can yes
done it if that we can do that we just
haven't yet implemented that especially
that in our case right I mean via
tablets language so it's hard 20 see
what come back from language well I know
but that's what the the Python stuff
that's what it's all about is dealing
with associations and converting them
and dealing with all kinds of things
right yes yes we can build that yes but
is it is but but what are the types that
unity natively deals with I mean so for
example if what came back here from they
evaluate was a you know polyhedral mesh
or something could you expect to deal
with that natively no why not because if
I don't it doesn't have it but you need
to have this you know a mesh type right
no but net obviously that's not gonna be
a native type Internet yes but the whole
point is that that's that's the thing is
that there will be some dotnet data
structure that I mean so there is a
function there is a function that does
convert that mesh into a an object in
the unity system right so I think the
key thing is that if you know any object
like if you have a mesh a geometric
object in mesh or a Karthik in the world
farm language but we can't
made them back to a corresponding unit
in mesh object right which is a class
for the unity editor
he said the unity editor right right
right and we currently do that where you
do a create game object for example but
you haven't done that for the world from
language evaluate so it is nice I say I
say okay all right fine I really think
you should look at um I mean I guess
between Todd gayly and Dorian you know
Todd worked on that link and and has
worked on the Java language client
library and Orion has worked on the
Python language client library these are
pretty well developed sort of callback
good systems obviously a little
different you know the darknet one is
more similar I don't really know it
depends on what the what the types that
unity can natively understand our um
that's interesting okay so what's this
menu so that's within unity yes why so
from you know in the unity menu we added
some you know several new item there
where for example you can call back to
the Wolfram and join to create some
geometry crazy scene geometry for
example whatever the heck is spiky it
was despite each was just I think but
these are these are unity objects is
that right or or these I mean the links
are confusing me because they're all
blue but but I mean is this are these in
fact links to unity classes no this
normally should be strained to just say
do you know the list of you know we are
still typesetting that that P is fine
but it so those should be strings
exactly okay I'm obviously okay but so
so so wait a minute so when when you
load when you do a unity open here it
preloads
some Wolfram package into unity that
among other things provides menus is
that correct yes okay so those
automatically allows the set of study
kernel extend the menu on set up all
the asset speech so within those menus
is there in fact a copy-paste location
where you can effectively just
copy-paste and evaluate thing I mean
that seems like it would be the most
look the coolest thing is you you're
chugging along in unity and you simply
have this object that you created in one
language and you just or this piece of
code and you would just paste that into
unity and it would just get run and
return the result to unity so you mean
just copy paste something from the
front-end and paste it into unity editor
well I'm saying I'm saying what I'm
suggesting is I mean they're different
ways you could do it so what one thing
would be I've got a piece of code I've
got a final you know I've got a you know
a random I don't know if this is a real
thing is that a real thing how many fall
what's that 40 I want something more
exciting
I give me something more exciting a
bigger one you go on let's step and
dedicate on much better okay
and then okay so what are you saying
here I should just okay fine
well okay so what I'm saying is let's
just say that I want to get my you know
uh let's say can I do
stellated polyhedra and of dodecahedron
or something and then why did that
why did dodecahedron just return itself
and stellated polyhedron of darling a
heater and returned a polyhedron thing
question 1 question 2 why does this
image look like it's greyed out well
question 1 is that do decay drawn it's a
basic primitive I see okay and why
shouldn't work why do you have to look
at it
deputies Basin seems to be a bit grayed
out but anyway ok magnificent so let's
so there's a stellated octahedron so the
question is what's the shortest workflow
path to get that started directly he'd
ran into unity I'm sold
well the shortest one you just do a
create the Unity game object of that
right but that's that's from the Wolfram
language side what I'm asking is if you
are looking at unity and somebody simply
is sending you a notebook or something
without you being connected so my
understanding is if you start up unity
with the Wolfram package in it yes which
you can do standalone you don't have to
say unity open from a Wolfram language
Colonel do you um know you can't start
the whole and one may see Paislee
without your thumb so is it the case I
mean are we intending to put it in some
unity store the the glue code so that
basically somebody can just go to the
Unity Store and download something where
they can have the Wolfram plug-in inside
unity on on startup for them
um yes that should be due to the way to
go yes ok so then they're gonna get that
and then my question is there
looking at some often language code and
they say I want that stellated
dodecahedron and how do I get it in
there because what seems to me would be
nice would be to have something where
maybe there's just an input field but
you just copy paste that code and you
say go and it runs that code in a
wolfram engine gets the result back to
unity and then you know then it appears
in the unity editor I see yeah we we can
add that we can for example just have a
a new item in the menu which allows
somebody to paste the word from language
code and then evaluate it on new kernel
existing local kernel and then just
paste belt of result seems that seems
useful to me um so that the two
scenarios one is exactly you know your
game developer you living in unity can
you get the utility to do various things
exactly and somebody could give you a
library of just click here and copy this
thing and stick it into unity I don't
know how unity stores so a question
would be can you store a call too often
language in the unity in the in your
unity project not the results from it
but the actual call yes it's um well in
the current version of watch it doesn't
work but is what we're building for a
unity deploy so you can essentially
store we store it has it tests inside
you know the unity object became object
yes we can do that okay someone from our
livestream mentions that a friend
implemented a lisp in unity to emulate
Emacs so they'd love a similar wolf
flying based interface but I wonder what
does what do they mean I mean oh I what
would that mean I mean I just don't
understand within unity you know the way
I see it it's primarily like a drawing
system as I understand it where you can
attach code to various objects in the in
the system but is that the wrong way to
think about it I mean is there it's sort
of it's a scene graph so
um and what are the big things as events
coming back you know collision events
and other things and you do things upon
those events okay so for us I mean okay
so let's talk about those callbacks
which I imagine is where is that that's
calling the Wolfram language from unity
that's what we were just on okay so
that's so your point is when to
dodecahedron skhul ID for example then
there is you can generate an event and
that event can call code is that correct
okay so the analog of that if you look
at the Python language client library
which I hope I have a link to let me
just take a look um but the other side
is that unity doesn't contain
functionality for creating objects
that's you know you create your creative
tools are somewhere else and then you
sort of give them to unity unity has no
functionality for creating we're very
poor you know what I wonder if I can get
some um ah there we go
Thank You Carla okay here we go
so is this do you know if this is the
latest version or is this some because I
know Dorian was working on some things
here so I think he's still working on
some styling issues but the contents
pretty pretty well done okay so take a
look at this type of thing okay so this
is just calling a Wolfram language
function WL dot min max calling it with
a Python list as an argument I'm making
sense what but
fight that a concept there is slightly
different way
Python is an antiquated line I know I
know I know I know I know
um right yeah I understand it's
different um but also there's a
practical issue - you don't want to call
the Wolfram engine in your game I mean
you could do it during development but
we have to do additional work to find
well you might want to it depends what
your game is doing I mean if you're you
know I mean you absolutely might want to
you don't want to on every single
collision of two balls or something but
you might want to in some more
sophisticated situation yeah but we
gotta solve the distribution problem you
know if you're gonna call it you know if
you're gonna distribute your game right
okay right then it should be a Wolfram
script callback which can either go to a
local Wolfram engine or to the cloud we
we are we do I mean there is that option
of the flood there is embedded code
where we can actually generate that
callback right so we have also the
support for unity there but I think me
an analog here like in the and the
Python language client library you are
in a position to simply say okay I want
this to run against the cloud or oh I
want this to run against a local engine
and the things that it can do analogous
to the Wolfram script look if you if you
look at the pure um I mean what I'm
saying is that you've got a clean
license terms for all that you know in
distribution terms I understand I
understand I mean that but that's what
we're doing with the Wolfram engine I
mean we have that opportunity with the
with the disembodied Wolfram engine but
but here I think we can do it but not on
this time scale right no no absolutely
not on this time scale I'm just trying
to understand the road map okay not
trying to understand the version 12
delivery okay go ahead so there is to
Keaton to to see here right so one thing
is that we
you know you called the Worf imagine
from unity in the unity editor the
binding we built is to the dotnet right
so it hopefully exactly similar to the
dotnet link mmm-hmm like the value today
and that binding actually provide us
enough power to control fully unity from
the Wolfram language and vice versa if
you go to do to the Wolfram script you
actually lost all that functionality
because all you can't do Hoffa speaking
is an evaluation oh no I know I'm not
I'm not saying I'm not okay
by the way color very minor thing could
you get that space I'm sure they okay
the the UM the point that I'm making is
the way B's it's worth looking at the
way these calls work okay that it can
call which is analogous to the way that
the Python calling works which i think
is analogous to the way that the java
calling works that is for example you
can have a a function that has been the
orphan language function and this calls
that function just like cloud function
it calls the function remotely but it
passes the arguments okay we do have it
so that's that's the example the basic
example it's done bedded code we chose
the call to the cloud like we do
embedded code for java and other things
you have this thing for unity okay okay
cool okay but so let's go back over here
and I see okay okay well alright so
where should we start here so you're
saying if you won one use case is you
are you have a live unity session and
you are pushing Wolfram language assets
into that live unity editor session so
to speak and those assets will then be
stored as part of your game is that the
idea that's one of the idea I mean you
have for control of the unity for
example you can actually control the
game
or dude eating of the [ __ ] from the
Wolfram language fully okay so are you
saying that if you're playing a Unity
game and you you know it's a multiplayer
game I don't know if this is a crazy
idea but I mean so for example could we
use our reinforcement learning could we
hook our reinforcement learning system
to well either a one player or multi
okay let's ask this question let's say
we want to do reinforcement learning
against a random unity game could we do
that
yes but we don't have it in place so
that was what I was discussing with
Etienne a while ago so I mean unity 20
actually is pushing it to that direction
of course learning where they have a
package haven't yet public URI easy but
he still on beta and they use tensorflow
for that essentially so we can pretty
much plug it on it is a framework for
that and you have different you know
external would you you can talk to it
and we can plug our self to account and
do that yeah okay okay but let's let's
review okay okay bigger picture okay so
one thing we're trying to do is to
provide a source of geometry primarily
geometry to you and also also images and
audio actually okay okay so a source of
assets for unity developers right I'm
presumably we're gonna have a marketing
page that explains these points yes
right but the other thing is that we can
also we haven't built many of these but
we can do more sophisticated assets kind
of generation so for instance if you
want a forest or a city Laura that will
follow right you know like point
processes stochastic point processes and
out of things you can build a model for
it you can generate them and then the
cost of those kinds of assets is very
low requires very human right that's
nice I mean it's like what was
originally done with with you know
Mathematica for
this the sims and so on for generating
all kinds of assets and so on and the
procedural generation of things right um
but um okay so that's so right
immediately right now what's there as of
right now is things like geometry
graphics images or do you imagine that
that that okay so somebody starts up a
game and they want to procedurally
generate a bunch of stuff and they want
to use you know Wolfram language in the
loop to procedurally generate that stuff
that is otherwise known as calling the
language inside the game right well I
don't imagine that unless we spend more
time on how that engine is gonna bundle
and how the license terms are going to
look but but but just to be clear the
the thing the Wolfram engine that we
have just been building right is
precisely intended to be an embeddable
Wolfram Anjan so yes the license terms
have to flow through the unity store and
all those kinds of things but the actual
asset that we have is the correct asset
we have to look at the ami night it
sounds like it but it's it's something
that's not quite ready yet and well
actually well actually it is ready
actually that particular thing is ready
but but been announced and because it
isn't that ready it's technically ready
um the you know and it is a plug-in
thing for Wolfram script where instead
of running against your you know Wolfram
1 installation or something you can run
against the Wolfman gene installation
right so I think that that's a
possibility I think we're gonna learn
something about size limitations I don't
know if they're big or not right okay so
one thing is static asset generation
another is Wolfram language in the loop
asset generation or Wolfram language in
the loop
you know AI in the game type today right
but but the other thing which is super
important this is a good way to teach
game development you can actually get
somewhere without taking horrible
you mean by using a notebook to document
what you're doing in the game
development exactly you know and that's
done a lot of you know high schools
community colleges and universities all
of the above
yeah no I understand so then then so one
thing you might be doing here is to have
a notebook based you know a simple game
development presented in a notebook is
that the idea
yes have an example of that yes in the
sample projects are simple they
particularly simple but those can be
developed much further
okay so this is but is not yet fully
formatted but you just to show how you
can you know build a piano form tool
from language from the cartoonist some
reason the way you say that Charles is
just funny that disembodied statement is
amusing okay all right so okay create
unity scene so what's that doing so it
first you open the project aren't in
project I mean a game have different
scene or level so know that create a
scene and after that then you need to
create the geometry Plaza material which
is in this case of color this this
create unity material yes is that it
there file that is there material file
or what yes does that's the file
understood is that our file or is that a
file that part of the standard unity
distribution no snow so that one
essentially when you say black you will
create a material you will create a file
a unity file material I see this is the
destination exactly so you take our
black and then map it down to do
appropriate oh okay so you have to put
the material into a file for unity to to
understand it right in this case yes why
I mean that's generally the case you you
can also assign material directly but
for this this game does the way we build
it okay you know if you're trying to
simplify it it seems obscure well
because we're playing to peruse the
material see part time so the way is too
much why don't we just store it in more
from language why do we have to push it
to a file in the unity file system no so
the game is actually built on the unity
side right so we have to push that
information to the unity side so you
have to tell him we are going to create
a key and the color will be black so
that's hopefully what we are saying
there create unity material black and at
the bottom I think okay so any object
plataforma properties material is this
butBut I don't understand why you don't
do it that this is a Wolfram language
object this became at as a Wolfram
language object that then all gets
packaged up when you say create Unity
game object why does that why are you
making that be an indirect reference to
a file where well yes defintely we can't
do that okay fine it's just nothing the
way of doing it okay but okay so then
this is create game objects for the
white keys so each one is its own
separate game object yes okay
create the black keys fine okay now
what's this okay so that's then what
that looks like in the unity scene graph
is that right
yes okay what's this what the hell's
this right so for unity to do some
control you need to write some C shop
code right so what we just did it in
this case a template because you need
you know when you press a bot on some
action happen we don't have that for
contour so you need to actually call the
unit animator so this is just a shortcut
we do and we push it to the unity side
but so when when when an asset like when
you touch a key in unity that generates
an event in this case where you touch an
object in unity it generates an event
for unity and this is the event handler
for that event is that correct yes in
the unity side so that the key do this
is actually keyboard keys keyboard key
so you see the I mean it javi a class a
mate would call update so every time I
don't know how many hundred frame per
second to Missy you know call me miss
account it's called that function and
then we check if the key was pressed and
then we called animate oh okay but that
animator is a is a unity class yes which
is generic or I mean doesn't have to
know what the key is gonna do doesn't
have to know the key is pivoting in some
way and so on right so below we actually
do those those those change in position
so essentially we up there is you know a
key each key Harvey it transform
component which carry the position based
on the Euler angle so we just have to
modify those position okay well so it
does
work at this point I mean in other words
if this was if I pressed one of these
keys in unity where would it where would
it determine the key press what does
that have to do with the I mean is that
the Euler angle that's involved now
surely not so this so essentially what
was happening so no so this one this
part was a camera did you find the
position of the camera was not deep okay
but where does it say what to do how to
move the key well it seems to be missing
here maybe the bigger camera huh big
bigger piano hazard no doesn't seem to
have it okay
no matter there's a piece of code
missing there yes yes they should be
ducked animate all right yes people on a
live stream have noticed puppeting unity
werewolf from notebook awesome yes it
does seem to me it's really it seems
pretty like a pretty nice thing um so
but now one of the things that we're not
able to do here which seems like a shame
in this notebook is that's a screen
capture right yes how would you use our
code to just pull that back as an image
from unity we actually have an example
which does that you have phones on to do
screen capture from the Wolfram language
to the unity or we have a we have a
generic screen capture function no we
actually in the unity package we build
unity screen captures okay okay but not
using the the usual current screen image
function for example right because we
have one at the Wolfram language level
we also have yes but you're doing one
it's specifically for the unity window
yes okay so so I guess that two things
we'll might imagine I mean one is to get
the screen capture and the other is to
get for example the you know some
representation of the scene graph
directly into a language the whole scene
graph yes we have the I mean so the way
will I mean we have the different object
which represent
I mean every game object will present
one element in this in half and then we
have a unity yashi cough he gives you
the hush of the scene cough has it weak
to what the hierarchy hierarchy graph so
you can manipulate it wow that's cool
can you show me an example of that of
where the scene graph actually shows up
as an actual graph in our language so
let's type unity okay actually another
question on the live stream that I'm
also curious about um it's some would
you be able to control unity based game
without having the source code for the
game no an essentially here we do that
control because inside the unity editor
since during the development process but
we don't Harvey know so you have to you
have to be able to instrument it during
the development of the game yes and we
really haven't even build in that
direction this is more about in the
stage where you actually do development
und detour mode you are using actually
unity right if you build again and you
have an executable binary well yeah it's
too late
is that so it doesn't it doesn't leave
okay so because the mono calls and
things can't be done to the binary is
that correct they're they're calls the
unity for example you can't extract the
scene graph of some random game that's
just running you know where you only
have the binary
I don't think so everything is already
compiled optimize and know um and for
for your question if you type unity a
[ __ ] calf okay
okay as it is it um if I gave labels
would it be M if I remember correctly I
that should correspond to live in the
calf right so this now works you know
the engine is currently running oh wait
you cannot start 12 them there was
already one awning okay so how do i and
it so something's happening here
oh it's importing something or other
okay so so one application of all this
stuff you know we talk about a bunch of
potential you know AR and VR
applications and putting our geometry I
mean so so what's the shortest path to
getting some random complicated forest
the you've got an orphan language into a
blank unity project is that is that a
meaningful question I mean so that you
can just go explore it in dr so to speak
create unity alright what is it
yes so any any geometry you have in the
world from language if you just push
that to your project are you can you
compare your project has he have your
object you will get it and is watch
actually we did that this see graphite
and also I joined the conference we demo
some of those well you can't take our
you know okay so I seem to have
something up here so what do I do if I
want to I want to push my I want to push
my polyhedron to that to that unity
system then you do a create
a game object created a game object
object we give it a name and % for
tickets or this one here maybe is that
the polyhedron or the graphics object um
let's go with the car thick because I
don't know if you are there Sean Hardy
okay so now what happens so if you go to
unity you should see Wow
well why does it not it doesn't look
right uses smooth normal to smooth it so
the shading default Peter look the same
as what we have that's actually the main
key because we have our shader to be
able to achieve that we need to
implement our [ __ ] on the unity side oh
gosh that's a pain yes right we just
purely the geometry okay so if I were to
take I mean okay so like for example if
I had um well that's pretty cool that
works I don't know how to use unity well
enough to see what to do with this but
can I don't even know how to rotate
around here um so you see on the top
left but you have that okay great
dan okay yep sorry go ahead
umm no pretty much I wanted to say so on
the right hand side you see the
inspector there we have you know the
mesh component is the one where actually
we study okay if I if I go to material
why does it say physic material is that
type over hours I'm hardly there typo um
okay but so how do I make it made of
brass or something can I change the
material or not yes I think if you
double-click on it um
select physic material is that is that
is that is that we should check that's
their type oh yeah dad's in window
that's we'd have no control on those so
it's that that type oh okay weird okay
but for some reason we don't have any
materials loaded no okay but so in this
case for example okay so for example if
I want to know what orientation so I had
been flapping around this creature here
yes wherever I don't know how to select
it I'm how do I find out what
orientation this thing wound up so this
unity game object so for example can I
move that if I move the Unity game
object or well I was just rotating it
should tell me how to get back the
rotation in here so if you say percent
45 and then you say transform component
transform component just house form
sorry some company like this yes to get
you some car you press on that plus sign
so you get do actual rotation mapping so
then you can do percent of rotation it
rather horrifying that those were your
angles on 10 degrees isn't that gonna
mess everything up I mean there are
degrees but they don't have a degree
sign oh I think you should fix that what
for before it gets even worse so to
speak I mean in other words you should
have them come back in to often
languages 319 degrees um okay but so if
I want to set if I wanted to move that
creature around can I set the Euler
angles of that thing for that game
object well a for shine ode on top of I
don't know but didn't do so essentially
if you do percent I mean let's call that
object obj or something object equal
percent 45 and there you can just see a
45 pocket position they just translated
as AJ what okay pocket
position and then you can give a
[Music]
position okay so if I say zero one zero
for example here okay i watch the unity
side probably click on it
all this maybe maybe i don't know how
big it is do we know how big it is
actually can you put double bracket like
part I'm sorry maybe I changed something
yes
it moved okay so if I if I click on the
unity thing so if I say this thing goes
to three there um and now I click here
tada
where did it go it did it exit the scene
yeah it's it's up there cool
okay okay that's really cool
very nice okay so I can go both ways so
I can both pick up that unity object and
okay that's super nice I mean let's see
so we should obviously reach out to
folks who do you know game development
above game development again I mean I
would have thought that you could then
script all kinds of things with this in
the notebook that would be really quite
gruesome to do in otherwise exactly um
okay but so the
is something yet different unity deploy
so okay so I think I understand these
things so this is creating a game object
pushing the game object to unity being
able to read back attributes of the game
object in Wolfram language I think I
understand that um so this unity play
thing is just literally remote
controlling the you know the play button
in the unity procession is that correct
yes going okay so from within unity
there's this callback mechanism okay
what is unity deploy um so that one's
going to have a bug but in principle
it's I mean what that was one of your
requests so for example if I have a warm
language if awesome and then I just want
to attach it to an object in unity so if
you do you need to deploy of that call
welcome language code then you know from
the unity we can call back the Wolfram
language that word from language code
essentially okay but how do i how do I
say where I want that code connected
into the unity scene graph right so
essentially you give the name of the
game object and you also specified which
method you want to be you know which one
you want to hundred to call back I'm
sorry I just have to try something I'm
just curious what happens if I say nest
that guy and say you know 1.5 or
something I've no idea what I'm really
doing here
but um okay and now I say graphics 3d of
that I just want to see what the
performance is like okay so I've got a
more elaborate creature like this let's
try let's try one point seven there okay
not so not too different okay so now now
I want to take this thing and I say and
let's see
what happened yeah discrete s graphic
failed okay well how I um that's mark
gematria
I think I mean the twenty should be
having discretization of graphics is
when you have several component okay
it's something you have to fix when is a
full mesh object or a boundary mesh
object we discretize it but when you
have several component we need to
actually do do this cottage is component
separately undo a boolean operation a
union and I think is why it's failing
okay so if I were to have um okay
what is there what's another thing that
I can do other than stellate but better
but what is it called dumb as all know
bevel bevel level so what is cool edie
devote oh my god what's it doing I might
be insane okay now let's do graphics 3d
of that
okay that's rather beautiful object now
so you think that will be easier for it
no why is that not working
simply descritization but I mean that's
a very smooth object what does it mean
what why are you doing a discretize
graphics anyway because we need to get
the geometry from a gothic you pretty
much don't have the geometry right well
okay so fine so I don't want to do the
graphic then let's do it from line 58
which doesn't have I mean yeah so so
that might be better well to not have to
reverse-engineer why did I try to recall
always the discretization the base code
discretization but I don't understand
why you have to discretize anything I
mean aren't you just trying to take the
geometric I think that there's another
limitation which i think is unity can
only have triangles in there
no they actually handle quad the quad
okay this beyond quad here but it the
key thing is that we need a wolf home
function which take that graphic and
actually give all the Qayamat we our
graphics never actually have the core
geometry I know but this has the
geometry right that polyhedron has the
geometry yes so why can't I just take
that polyhedron and feed it to unity yes
that's it that's something I need to fix
in the discretized graphic okay but but
this is not discretizing and graphic
because this isn't a graphic that's just
a pure it's a graphics geometry is it
class white well well I should say what
we call is the same disk with as graphic
but yes it's not okay okay fine okay so
this will work it's your basic claim yes
that would work
and will it work reasonably fast I mean
is it going to you know if I have a
thing with some you know ten thousand
polygons they're gonna be like no
problem or is it going to be like
creaking shouldn't I mean lately we have
been trying to fix that if you avoid
computing the normal it should be pretty
fast because he strophe did donate Jenny
Marie transfer okay what what is the
business about computing normals because
unity tries to create normals to do
shading we actually currently add
enormous to make it a smooth surface I
mean to have that form shadow type thing
it's like in case where you have to put
it on there I mean that would occur at
home yes
it's moot because we added the normal
which maybe we should into by default
I wouldn't especially if it takes a lot
of time I mean or if there's an easy way
I mean it shouldn't it be an option to
specify whether you want polygon normals
added yeah she should be
right I mean okay
all right what else should we make sure
that I mean this looks quite lovely
quite wonderful actually um I mean
except for the fact that it's totally
confusing because they're all blue links
here um what else should we make sure to
look at right now I mean this is
obviously a rich thing and I would love
to learn more I think also
can have quite a lot more development to
them you know both from within the
Wolfram language higher level functions
right and from within from in unity of
how to call and get sort of you know
useful really useful cases but I think
we already need to reach out to some
actual customers and see what I mean the
most we've had a beta test with a bunch
of actual customers okay and I mean I
think they're people in the VRA our
world who we should be reaching out to
their people who want to use this
essentially so just let me understand
something I mean so one of the use cases
is using unity as like a totally
souped-up manipulate how would that work
with this set up is that I mean in other
words let's say that you want to I mean
that that was the case um that you know
those guys in Texas were doing for oil
and gas um it's not really I mean I
looked at what they did that wasn't what
they did okay
well but but one thing one could imagine
that they could have done okay is that
you've got a Unity game and it is being
used to control something which is being
simulated either in Wolfram language or
through system model or for example yes
and then there are many of these
developments that we haven't hooked up
you know there's more the system modular
connections there's machine learning
connections there are more things to
sort of bring online with this even from
the Wolfram language fair enough
and there are higher level functions you
know that not only sort of raw
technologies like that but there are
higher level functions to be built but
currently do I mean the base the base
module we have can I lose somebody with
some programming to do that we have a
couple of example where you can actually
do something similar so you can be on
the Unity movie arm your object and then
you see on the Wolfram site some
language sighs the object moving inside
the dynamic well that's cool yeah
well it's very nice I mean as you say
there's lots of stuff that could be done
with this I just I just hope that the
you know the various communities that
should care about this can actually get
reasonable access to it I mean in the
sense that we you know that they
understand what it is well enough um I
mean clearly there's some important work
to be done and making marketing pages
probably not just version 12 marketing
pages but a separate unit e-link
marketing page um that I I don't know
whether you guys have worked on it all
or not well we've thought about it and
it and and the question is sort of
mostly resources and yeah all right well
great I mean okay I should go to my next
meeting here but but um this is
interesting too gosh there's a lot of
wonderful stuff here um what does that
do in terms of logging game States I'm
sorry does it does just give states of
Unity game objects or what does it do um
yes so essentially it was he so you when
you have a game you just add that
component which is embedded in the world
am i said and you essentially
automatically feed the information about
your game to edit a bean so the position
where the player had the action of the
player or the user where vice okay
although I mean in some format it's
added to the database and probably the
format matters yes aunt we had a
template notebook where you can actually
wait that it a bean and you get
statistic about yeah okay I've got to go
to another meeting but um this is great
and yeah III really think a marketing
page would be worthwhile we can talk
about what you know how that should be
slaughtered in um you know we'll build a
marketing page for 12 for sure I
understand that but I think the other
one sure if it's you know separate
discussion it should also be talked
about with the partnerships group and so
on exactly um okay great
for people on the live stream we are
about to go to
yet another meeting on a completely
different topic so maybe we'll see that
thanks for your participation and see
y'all soon okay bye